So far we've learned what a
complex number is; we've even
learned how to graph it.
And we learned how to add,
subtract, and multiply it.
Where I left off in the last
video was, how do we divide
two complex numbers.
So I said, let's say I have
one complex numbers, z1.
And that equals a plus b i.
i.
And I want to
divide that by z2.
Which is, c plus d i.
So let me ask you a question.
And I touched on this
in the last video.
And let me do it in a
different color over here.
We know that a plus b times
a minus b is equal to a
squared minus b squared.
And you can multiply it out,
in case you're not sure.
Remember, it's just a times
a plus b times a minus
a times b, plus a times
a, and you'll get this.
But you know how to
do this, anyway.
There's a review of it,
if you need to do it.
So, given that,
what is c plus d?
What happens if we do
something very similar
with a complex number?
If we say c plus d i
times c minus d i.
Well, in this case a is c.
And b is d i, right?
So this is just going to
be equal to c squared
minus d i squared.
d i squared.
And that equals c squared
minus d squared i squared.
minus d squared.
And i squared is
negative 1, right?
So this is going to be
multiplied by negative 1, so
it cancels out this negative.
So you get c squared
plus d squared.
That's interesting.
When I multiply a complex
number times this other number,
which is very similar to it,
but it's kind of the imaginary
part, goes in the
other direction.
When I multiply the two, I get
a completely real number.
All of the i's disappear.
And, in general, this number --
if we call this -- well, in our
example this was z2, so if we
say that z2 equals c plus d i,
the quantity c minus d i
is called its conjugate.
And that's just good
terminology to know.
And the sign for conjugate
is that line over the top.
So the conjugate of
z2 is c minus d i.
Or you could say, the
conjugate of c minus d i
is equal to c plus d i.
Or you could say it
the other way around.
The conjugate of c plus d i
is equal to c minus d i.
And notice, we're just
switching the direction in
the imaginary -- along the
imaginary axis, when we take
the conjugate of something.
With that said, let me
erase that and go back
to our original problem.
Because the conjugate is
the tool we're going
to use to divide this.
So we know when we multiply an
imaginary number times its
conjugate, we get
a real number.
And we know, also, if we
multiply -- we can multiply
anything by 1, and we
get the same number.
So let's multiply the numerator
and denominator of this
expression by the conjugate
of the denominator.
So let me do that.
So the conjugate of the
denominator is going
to be c minus d i.
So c minus d i
over c minus d i.
So this was c plud d i, so
this is its conjugate.
And so what do we get?
So in the numerator, we get a c
-- I don't want to run out of
space, I always do -- a c, so a
times c, minus a d i, minus a d
i -- these i's are looking
funny -- this is an i.
Plus b c i; plus b c i.
And then the last term, we
have a plus b minus b.
So it's minus b d i squared.
Minus b d i squared.
All of that.
And this is a plus
b times a minus b.
So it's equal to a
squared minus b squared.
So this is going to be equal to
-- and it this will become
second nature to you after a
while, but you might want
to just multiply it out.
This equals c squared
plus d squared.
And don't take my word for it.
Actually, algebraically,
multiply this out and just
realize you can only add real
parts to real parts and
imaginary parts to
imaginary parts.
So let me simplify that.
That equals -- let's
see, the real parts.
This is real, a c.
And this is minus
b d i squared.
So the i squared is minus 1.
So it switches the sign here,
so it becomes plus b d.
And we can get rid of d i.
So the real parts
are, a c plus b d.
That's that, and that.
And then the imaginary parts
are plus -- this one's
positive, so I'll put one first
-- b c minus a d i, all of that
over c squared plus d squared.
And that still might not look
like a complex number to you.
But then we can separate them
out and we could say well,
that equals a c plus b d over
c squared plus d squared.
And that's the real part.
Plus b c minus a d over c
squared plus d squared.
And that times i, and
that's the imaginary part.
So you can't merge, when you're
adding and subtracting, the
real part to the
imaginary part.
But you can most definitely
scale an imaginary
number by a real number.
And that's essentially
what we're doing.
We're multiplying 1
over c squared plus d
squared times this.
So, division might seem a
little complicated when I
write it all in variables.
But let me give you an example
and you will hopefully see that
it -- with real numbers, and
-- not real numbers, with
actual numbers, I should be
careful with what I say.
Let's say I have 1 plus 2 i.
And I want to divide that by, I
don't know, let's divide it by,
I'm going to pick
a random number.
2 plus 3i.
And so what do we do?
We multiply it times the
conjugate of the denominator.
2 minus 3i over --
over itself, right?
Because then we're not
changing the number.
This is just 1, this
simplifies to 1.
It equals -- the bottom,
we can multiply it out.
But hopefully it's
second nature to you.
It equals 4 plus 9, right?
Because that's just a
squared plus b squared.
Right?
Well, I mean, it's a squared
minus b squared, but then the
i's, when you multiply, and it
becomes a negative number.
Try it out if you
don't believe me.
And then the top, we
get 1 times 2 is 2.
1 times minus 3i is minus 3i.
And you have 2i times
2, which is plus 4i.
And then you have
2i times minus 3i.
So that's minus 6.
Minus 6i squared.
Well, what does i
squared equal?
That equals negative 1.
So negative 1 times negative 6.
Get rid of the i squared and
this becomes a positive.
So then, what are
our real parts?
Our real parts are 2 and 6.
so 2 plus 6 is 8.
And what are our
imaginary parts?
Minus 3i plus 4i.
So that's just plus 1i, right?
Minus 3 plus 4 is positive 1.
So it's just plus 1i.
Over 13.
Or we could write that as -- if
we wanted to write that in the
traditional complex form --
is 8/13 plus 1 over 13i.
So when I divided one complex
number by another, I got
another complex number.
And an interesting exercise
for you to do is, pick some
random complex numbers.
Plot them out on complex plane,
and see what happens when you
multiply them, when you divide
them, when you add them,
when you subtract them.
And when you scale them.
Or when you take the conjugate.
And that'll give you a better
intuition of what's going
on with these numbers.
Anyway, I will see you
in the next video.